i really want to talk about this let me
see if i can find the right tweet ah
here we are uh i would like to offend
all of the feminists real quick uh with
this tweet that i have right so this is
my offensive tweet as you know today uh
kamala harris assumed the role of acting
president the powers of the president
for i believe about two hours was it
and i thought about this i was thinking
about
you know everyone tweeting madam
president kamala harris is now the
president and then i was like what a way
to gain the power of the presidency so
here's what i tweeted
the first woman with the power of the
presidency will forever go down in
history as receiving her power due to
the sitting president getting his ass
examined
so the story was biden had to go for a
colonoscopy and go under anesthesia
which means the power of the presidency
had to be trended to the vice president
temporarily everyone then said this is
it the first woman with the power of the
presidency and i'm like man that's awful
historical precedent
imagine a school where the teacher is
like does anybody know how our first
president gained his power oh george
washington he was leading the revolution
against the british for independence
that's right and what about our first
female president oh the sitting old
white male president had to get his butt
examined so she temporarily gained the
powers and it's like why do we know this
what is this public information tmi yeah
honestly why is it public information
yeah i don't know i mean
if somewhere to attack us in those two
hours you maybe want to know who has the
button or who's in no but why do we need
to know that it's a colonoscopy yeah
yeah
okay okay yeah yeah
just imagine this
kamala harris is you know standing in
the hallway of the hospital by and walks
up right up to we're holding the nuclear
football and he goes madam vice
president she goes mr president the
nuclear football is yours for
two hours let's get this butt stuff done
did you say that trump didn't go under
general anaesthetic so that he could
have his colonoscopy and not have
but the report was trump didn't want to
hand over power to
pence so he took the colonoscopy
without his
you don't have to go maybe it's
different with age but you actually
don't have to go under when you do a
colonoscopy it's not like a requirement
if you get older that that's going to be
slack anyway isn't it it's just going to
fall straight up there
i mean it's cool
to figure out why he's been pooping his
pants right that makes sense like that's
the reason i wanted to have colon cancer
i bet they pushed the butt story because
they didn't want people to think it was
neurological ah maybe it's true
because because because maybe it was
something different is this a false flag
but i think you're actually wrong
because we've had two butt stories we
have three butt stories now with jokes a
lot of butt stories yeah there was the
the long fart right right right so
there's this this is interesting
i will spit my water out okay hold on we
did a segment what like a year ago a
year and a half ago a year or so because
joe biden was on tv and he farted yeah
it's like you play it you're up
it was like nasty
so when this new story came out in the
past week or so
that this camille dutchess said joe
biden let out a really long fart all of
a sudden i'm looking at the analytics on
our youtube channel we see the spike in
views on a video from a year ago and
it's joe biden farts and we were like
but then there's also
joe biden met with the pope i believe
right yeah he was supposed to have a
meeting and then he was supposed to come
out but something happened where he like
disappeared for a half an hour and then
came out with new clothes on
and so people thought he had a a he
pooped his pants bathroom incident no no
no no hold on there's i don't think
there's evidence to suggest that was the
case he may have spilled wine maybe sure
right and they were like uh what do i do
and he got he can't go out with a wine
stain it doesn't take that long to get
changed though half an hour
so what do you think shower yeah i mean
there's no speculation or speculating
i'll put it this way we get a story
about a fart
maybe that was the lead up to failing
you know rectal muscle or whatever yeah
then we get the accusations that he
pooped his pants now we're hearing he's
getting a colonoscopy yeah don't worry
everybody it's a routine it's routine i
think he's got butt problems 100
don't open those games
if i was kamala i would not brag about
this or let this be my legacy talk about
the time that you were president for two
hours because of that i'd be like
just run again kamal i don't like you so
maybe don't run again but i got another
bit
oh boy
there's gonna be kids in school and
they're gonna be watching a video the
teacher's gonna put on and it's gonna be
abraham lincoln i was president during
the americans uh you know
during the american civil war fighting
to keep the union together and end the
moral injustice of slavery it was a
contested election but i fought hard to
preserve the union and they're going to
flip the next page i'm kamala harris i
assumed the powers of the presidency
because the president above me had to
get his butt examined after farting and
pooping his pants
legacy glorious camilla parker bowles is
the woman
yeah can find that one yeah yeah it was
unavoidable apparently she was very
embarrassed i mean this is this is look
at this is we have politico no joe
biden's fart and oh what is this okay
joe biden's fault and other embarrassing
royal moments for americans
u.s president let's rip at cop 26
meeting with commonwealth crapping on my
nation here yes
oh the puns yeah you know at some point
puns were like the peak the epitome of
humor yes they still are i like i guess
i like them they're great yeah i don't
want to be too hard on this guy for
ripping ass
we all do it everyone's experience sound
like a guilty party here i'm definitely
guilty
i'm happy i'm happy you're not sitting
next to me tonight stop you guys
look look look i'll actually say
yeah i don't want to come down an old
man he's just old for pooping his pants
yeah that's all right but come on if
you're at the point where you're having
bathroom accidents then maybe you
shouldn't be president that's right
maybe
i don't know what about those control
pants yeah yeah the depends yeah yeah
yeah yeah well they actually don't they
sell like uh um adult like elderly
clothes that have you know i didn't
addiction
milton built-ins i don't think so yeah
oh okay look like i understand
incontinence like if you have to buy
diapers because you wet yourself and
stuff but if you're pooping in your
pants you have bigger issues yeah yeah i
mean like that's not something you you
look if if you're wearing a diaper
and you pee your pants you know you piss
yourself
no one's really gonna notice you'll be
uncomfortable but if you take that done
people do people are gonna smell them
and they're gonna be like oh
it's offensive it's very it is and i
will say she did get the presidential
power a lot sooner than i thought i
thought he'd at least make it to
midterms without having to hand it over
hold on didn't make it i just had a
realization i'm going to walk all this
back oh this is great we have the best
president ever what's that think about
it i'm thinking joe biden walks in to
meet with kim jong-un
they've been doing nuclear tests
he walks in and kim jong-un is thinking
like i'm going to handle this
negotiation they got nothing oh
and then biden sits down and says i can
sit here all day and kim jong's like no
no whatever you want please we just have
to weaponize the doo-doo right
we have to use it for our advantage it's
not the dude it's dangerous it's the
bacteria that grows on it yeah so
everyone's clear too but biden's gonna
be like
you know he's like i can sit here all
day all day
oh yeah and then like he uses the
vladimir putin and vibe my pawns like
this is not funny anymore
because then when it gets in the walls
the smell every time you smell it you
remember that moment
why have you thought this through
something like that
yeah you went through a whole narrative
i've known a lot of people
biden's sitting with like vladimir putin
and they're looking at each other and
then biden just starts shuffling his
butt in the chair and then putin's like
my chair stop stop
and then everyone's like oh they're
holding their noses and they're like we
give anything you want please just leave
right
maybe that's what it was we met with the
pope he was like i got some demands pope
and the pope was like i don't have time
oh
no i'm kidding i i i'm really i'm not
confident
you know what it feels like i think it's
really obvious what happens
people hated donald trump yep the
atlantic writes that story stay alive
joe biden all we need is your corporeal
form
people vote for anything they would look
for ham sandwich at that point and they
literally voted in the guy that we all
knew was decrepit and incapable the
onion has that very funny article where
it says presidency already ages joe
biden in 10 years and it shows a rotted
corpse like just that was their image
like even the onion was like dude this
guy's too old to be president yeah every
leftist i know concedes that there's
none i don't know many leftists who are
like yeah he's he's doing good he's on
top of his game power no he's he's old
and he's fading away and it's sad and
it's somewhat elder abuse to put in that
position but yes definitely especially
if you watch video from like even eight
years ago of him even just a few years
ago i watched an interview with him
recently where he was on the view
because i'm
you know i like torturing myself i
watched the view and like it was i think
in 2018 and he was there like he was
talking but but the older you get the
faster you decline two years is like 10
when you're that old the difference
between whatever it was 30 40 years ago
at his absolute peak and now is crazy he
was really sharp yeah right
easy it's crazy like yeah he has a
stutter and i'm like no he's got
something he's got dementia
yeah he's old man i interviewed him
before
about some
deep like like deep deep down the rabbit
hole stuff and he was on it he was like
this was a few few years ago and he was
you know
like he was lying but he was lying on a
level where other politicians weren't
even that competent to lie as quickly
and as effectively as he did so there's
been multiple incidences where i was
kind of surprised at how how well he is
up there now i i think you know there's
a lot of people being like they're just
bringing out different versions of him
out every day uh because
there's always something there's always
an incident that shows how much of in
decline he is and it's kind of sad to
see really you know how there's those
rumors about the president's having body
doubles and stuff like that that's a bad
gig isn't it yeah i could see it yeah
being joe biden but if you have a
president like if you have a president
who's not there wouldn't you want to use
the body double many times what was that
remember that weird photo of hillary
clinton that just did not look like
hillary clinton yeah yeah especially
after she collapsed when she felt oh my
god that she collapsed
and then there was she collapsed and
then there was another moment where she
had a small child run up to her and then
it came out she had i think uh uh
infectious disease
and then and then she's waving and like
brought a little child in to do a little
pr and then she stood very far away from
the camera and and there was a lot of
physical different and and facial
differences than what she normally looks
like remember that video where she spits
up into her glass
yeah she was like doing a speech
yeah she she they were like she has
pneumonia i'm like i think she probably
did have pneumonia yeah but like trying
to hide it and campaign through that
weird was gross and dangerous here's my
question though because as we're talking
about these old politicians fading away
how in any reality does joe biden make
it through even one full term and i'm
not trying to be mean i'm not trying to
say i wish anything but like
we're not even halfway through his first
year we are halfway through his first
year how mushrooms
well no so yeah
we're a couple months away from one year
for biden yeah and and people are
already like is he gonna be president
next year like is he gonna have to step
down
yeah and this degree of uncertainty is
really not good for us because like we
can't we're already really uncertain
we're already not friends with our
neighbors putting someone
this was always elder abuse from the
beginning i was like well i think
they're just using biden as a way to
ramp through all the horrible policies
that they that any other president would
be this is absolutely ridiculous this is
crazy i think the only way they could
push this nonsense is with someone who's
not really there yeah and i think
they're using him as this kind of fall
guy at the end of his career he's been a
career politician ram everything that's
extremely unpopular that's going to tank
his numbers and he's the frankenstein
president they're going to they're the
rumor is they're going to leapfrog
buddha judge over harris for 2024. yeah
he sounds like obama he talks like judge
doesn't have what it takes
no no no but he does have the cia
connections that doesn't matter you
still need charisma they didn't think
trump was going to win and the reason
trump did is because he'd be up on stage
and they'd be like a question for mr
rubio um rubio you said that you'd like
to raise taxes trouble go excuse me
excuse me no little marco you'll get
your time we're gonna talk about the
work and he just shut everybody down
yeah and so they're like what is he what
is he doing like this is not how the
game is played and they didn't know how
to play
chess uh play checkers against a guy who
was playing chess i'm not gonna pretend
trump was playing forty chess my point
is trump was just on a different level
yeah and that doesn't have the balls
but then again he was mayor of a small
town in indiana oh yeah but kamala's a
non-starter as well though right right
oh definitely absolutely backed into a
corner so what happens roll it forward
what do you think the democrats do the
only thing
i'm rethinking a little bit though that
they would be fully like buddha judge
might have a chance because leftists are
very concerned with appropriateness
they're very concerned with people who
can just say the right things
regurgitate talking points be very
proper
like maybe and they'll push the gay
narrative oh yeah of course oh my gosh
that's what's going to be it's going to
be the first openly gay president yes i
criticize him yeah but i believe that
that we're entering a period where
people would vote for a ham sandwich
over a democrat i think so with that new
jersey state senator guy we talked about
all the time
and i think
people have just
this has been a bad year it's been a bad
year and the media's want to admit it
and die hard urban democrats don't want
to admit it either but inflation
you see that tweet where it was like
experts are stunned are shocked that
inflation is happening right and it's
like how are the expert economists
shocked when like random grandpa online
you know grandpa joe 33 is like there's
inflation and i'm mad about it
i saw like random like not even
super intellectual people like nine
months ago being like inflation's coming
get ready y'all it's like so what are
the experts doing then yeah right
yeah they do they lie up until like the
week
that's what they do this was the
economist the economist ran that
headline they were like sharp increases
in inflation blindsided many economists
almost no one saw it coming i'm like
yeah bull crap what have you been doing
what is it
mind boggling it's getting to the point
where i see the word expert and i think
okay so an idiot yeah
which it's not how it should be we
should have faith in the system and we
should have faith in the people that we
prop up to like guide us through certain
things but it's just not how it is
anymore it's like
we you you've got random dude yelling at
camera predicts inflation that's me i'm
like sitting in my room i'm like man if
they print all this money and borrow
those money it's gonna be inflation
right it's called that and then the
experts are like he's certainly wrong
and then a year goes by and they're like
we're shocked by this i'm sitting here
like dude
you're just lying yeah you look at what
fauci did with the masks in the very
beginning of the pandemic and they told
people you don't need them they're not
effective because they wanted they
didn't want to instill a panic in a rush
on the mess they do the same thing with
the economy during the great depression
up until right up until the stock market
crash they were saying everything's
gonna be fine and everything's great
it's better than it's ever been inside
yeah they were they were it was like
1929 i'm talking about but i know i know
i agree but i'm saying in 2007 and
they're like everything's fine
everything's fine and then it crashes
and they're like oh
oh yeah oh how did this happen well and
then they all kind of like look at their
watches and like
kind of trying to defuse the blame i
mean who are you going to blame about it
it's hard to blame someone for the
entire economy the reason they do it is
because they're like hey we know the
apocalypse is here financially but if we
tell people it'll happen faster so just
sell you know sell now and then let it
crash and then buy back yeah and that's
what they do every time how nice nancy
pelosi i love those tick tockers that
track her stock purchases they're like
just buy what she does because she's
she's as corrupt as they come inside
track man she knows well they passed the
laws they know what bill's about to get
passed and so they're like
hey the news about this tech firm
getting you know uh getting fined you
know or getting shut down because of our
new bill is gonna hurt the stock short
them and it's going to help their
competitors so you invest in their
competitors that's right there's people
on tick tock making entire careers off
of nancy lee nancy pelosi picks which
have higher dividends than bitcoin oh
wow yeah dang wild why aren't i doing
that
i'm just gonna say i need to look at
these tick tocks millennial financial
advisors what we do in your portfolio is
very simple we follow nancy pelosi
exactly and invest as she does that's
literally what happens
that's one of the horsemen of the
apocalypse
absolutely absolutely yep
ah it's a crazy country we live in but
you know i will say today
white pill right this is a good day
we're all fairly optimistic we we we
look at what happened with kyle
rittenhouse justice was served kyle
should not have been on trial in the
first place that's why i say the whole
thing's fairly a net negative but gun
right victories yes the right to keep
and bear arms the gun charge dismissed
we're seeing it across the board
uh demands for gun control is low the
lowest it's been i think since like 2014
people are just saying and liberals too
young millennials gen z because even on
the left they're pro-gun
this is why we're not going to become
australia no matter how bad things get
here we're not going to become australia
yep thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time